yeah hello welcome to in the video um so
what should I play it's a five-minute
game which means i should hurry up here
okay i'll go for something else in the
clothes has been known here check with
noni salmon so quite a decent opening
actually it's not so bad it's a bit down
it's a bit passive looking like except
the some disadvantage in space and the
center but he's got some some
interesting ideas connected with this
you can play for f5 or b-five or various
other pawn breaks okay now why term
really go some just a little bit over
the top here already so on this this
maneuver here is designed to to exchange
the the dark squared bishop so I'm going
here trying to get rid of the bishop
okay he tries to prevent it but i try to
insist also yeah i can do that but i
have blocked response now and it so it's
questionable if this is a good position
for white f3 is no weakness i can even
try to play Queen f6 here may be
attacking f3 and he would have a hard
time to protect this Queen Queen here
quindi one another ID on Queen f6 might
be maybe not be five the other ideas 9 2
h 3 which is also not bad asking the
bishop vet where it should go I think
I'll do that
very we had set up here but I'm actually
making sure that the dark squared Bishop
get exchanged I would like to play Queen
to g5 and actually I can yeah I can play
this move I was a bit worried about not
be five at some point but ok needs to
deal with this first and if he exchanges
which would be really bad for him I
would take with the edge porn and then
have the H file open wow this looks like
a disaster really for white long-term
the H porn here I've got the rook I've
got everything blocked very nicely and
this I can just answer with King e7 and
it's just just doing nothing here I can
I can kick this night out with a 6 at
any time so should i do that yeah I
guess so it's been annoying to UM to
watch this night all the time so what is
what is his idea I mean I can always
drop the night back to F form and g6
also always controls the f5 square so
you cannot go Knight to f5 at some point
my dear simple I just want to UM ya pal
up on the edge file okay but he's got
the night on f1 to have this covered hmm
interesting it's so it's very nice
looking but not so one hundred percent
clear-cut how I should should win maybe
I even need to need to play a five at
some point ok first song hold the Queen
side mmm
maybe here I have the idea to maybe even
take take on before and play a five it's
got no pizza on on c5 which might be a
bit which would be a problem with this
kind of idea but it doesn't have a piece
doing this all right so Bishop a form
maybe ok then I could play b5 also hmm
how to say I want to have the option of
97 this idea taking on before and a 52
54 for the c5 square 97 now we might
play Bishop f4 can't try this idea now
more black
this night is still a bit annoying for
him all right
so take on before you takes with the
rupiah I take on life ok oh no no no
what would no no I can take on a foreign
maybe play b5 play be five this is good
I think mmm try to use some actually
that that my rook sign to play here if
he takes rook takes I have been pinned
down before and i just opened up now the
position alright so takes on c4 I
might've be five so i take here you
might have might be five okay
interesting okay so we'll take here
quite an interesting position don't
think I should try to protect c4 I want
this night on c5
ok
this poem is lost anyway so don't mind
so much he goes here i have the square
94 Chuck time morning so I just want
this beep on and still have a brilliant
night on deform just a bit down on time
but it's not not so so dramatic we're
taking this off sat night now if he
takes I will attack the night again with
Lou Kanye aah so on and this allows
allows me to get the second night into
play you could check out so what this
looks like a good move also he takes out
half a bee porn alright this beef one
should be nice and now rook a two should
be nice attack here the knight center
and the rook can easily be a quick mate
and well in this position is just a rack
here cannot cannot do much
hmm sooo gay too I can also pin here
what no 94 maybe everything's good just
a nasty pin now we need to be cautious
about I cannot cannot trade everything
off here this was bad really so yeah the
time check
I should have taken the drum all really
yeah it's still completely dead yeah
time of the issue again what's the
complete what was just what was just
destroyed him but time what so what's
the easiest here now he can- they look a
2 2 f2 or something it's just just wins
yeah 92 what is also not bad yeah it was
a I was just a bit too slow here alright
but quite an interesting game from a
strategic point of view on what white
Aditya was really terrible giving up all
the dark squares on the King side but
well it does it help if you take too
much time alright thanks for watching